gracias por tomarte este tiempo para ti
para lo que espero sea un agradable
viaje interior comienza por sentarte
idealmente en una silla firme con la
espalda erguida y los pies bien
plantados en el piso y descansa la
mirada si aún tienes los ojos abiertos
cierra los suavemente
a mí me gusta apoyar las manos sobre mis
piernas con las palmas hacia el cielo
pero ponlas donde te sientas más cómodo
y luego con los ojos cerrados poco a
poco por atención en tu respiración
intenta hacerla cada vez más profunda y
lenta
a tu propio tiempo inhala
y exhala
un poco más profundo un poco más lento
la idea principal de la meditación es
intentar reducir todo el parloteo que
existe en nuestra mente tratando de
aplacar nuestros pensamientos y mientras
hacemos esto y en cada meditación
intentaré introducir algún marco algunas
formas de ver tu mente pero mientras
intenta silenciar tu mente se va a
distraer de manera inevitable se va a
distraer con algún sonido en la
habitación o algún ruido de afuera o más
probablemente se va a distraer con
pensamientos que surgirán de tu
conciencia y si eso sucede no te pongas
ansioso mucha gente al meditar les
preocupa no estar haciéndolo bien y si
se distraen la situación empeora piensan
que nunca serán capaces de meditar
lo importante es acercarse a la
meditación con una actitud divertida de
curiosidad con sentido del humor todos
somos humanos y hacemos cosas muy
humanas así que cuando te des cuenta de
que tu mente está divagando solo ríete y
de ahí vas de nuevamente vuelve a la
calma no es ningún problema no te
castigues por eso y como parte de esto
durante la meditación trata tanto como
sea posible de mantener una sonrisa en
tu rostro
tus ojos están cerrados pero puedes
sonreír un poco al menos con tu mente
eso te ayudará a recordar que debe de
ser divertido relajante
dicho esto
sigamos inhalando
y exhalando
un poco más profundo
un poco más lento
y el marco que quiero presentarte para
silenciar tu mente es uno que uso mucho
imagina todos tus pensamientos de tu
subconsciente en un océano en la
superficie del océano es el punto de
contacto entre tu subconsciente y tu
conciencia
la mayoría de nosotros tenemos una
superficie muy agitada hay muchos
pensamientos brincando dentro y fuera de
nuestro subconsciente y muchas veces nos
ahogamos en esos pensamientos
una forma de ver esto es que podemos
elevar nos podemos elevarnos sobre la
superficie del agua y cuando comienzas a
hacerlo ya no está reprimiendo tus
pensamientos sino que estás mirándolos
desde arriba
puedes ver que siguen ahí que la
superficie sigue agitada que hay olas
pero conforme te elevas y los miras
desde arriba te das cuenta que no eres
esos pensamientos que tú no eres la
superficie del agua ya sea que lo que te
preocupa es una tarea que debes realizar
o alguna relación interpersonal o
simplemente algo en tu vida que no está
funcionando como te gustaría recuerda
eso no eres tú no te defines por el
resultado de esa situación sólo son olas
en la superficie
y a medida que permaneces por encima de
ellas que puedes verlas y analizarlas te
das cuenta de que no tienen control
sobre ti y cuando eso sucede las cosas
comienzan a tranquilizarse la superficie
del agua se torna más calmada más
calmada
más calmada
y tú continúas ahí
flotando sobre la superficie
pura conciencia
y te das cuenta de que eres mucho más de
lo que creías que eras no solo eres tu
cuerpo físico no solo eres esos
pensamientos que ves como olas en la
superficie del océano
ni siquiera eres solo esa identidad que
asocias contigo tu nombre tu lugar en el
mundo tu estatus lo que la gente piensa
de ti tus relaciones todos esos son
aspectos de ti pero no son tú
tú eres algo mucho más grande que todos
esos eres el espacio donde ocurren donde
se presentan pero no son tú
ahora intentemos permanecer en esa
conciencia pura durante el siguiente
minuto y de nuevo si tu mente divaga no
hay problema es solo la agitación de la
superficie del agua solo necesitas
volver a elevar la conciencia pura y si
te molesta el silencio no te preocupes
volveré en un minuto
muy bien
ese fue un lapso relativamente corto
para estar contigo mismo
conforme hagamos meditaciones más
avanzadas date cada vez más tiempo con
el tiempo no me necesitarás guiándote
quizás incluso te moleste serás capaz de
sentarte y simplemente aplacar tu mente
y de darte cuenta de que no eres tus
pensamientos y que las cosas que te
molestan sólo lo harán si tú se lo
permites en el panorama amplio de las
cosas en todo el tiempo y el espacio
ninguna de ellas es lo que debe definir
t ni se acercan a ser tan importantes de
lo que a veces hacemos que parezcan
nos vemos en la siguiente meditación